salut aujourd'hui je reviens avec une
petite énigme un petit truc un petit peu
rapide construite sur le thème de l'été
parce que c'est les vacances vous allez
imaginer qui a huit personnes qui
sortent d'un hôtel ils vont à la plage
c'est juste avant ils doivent aller voir
quelqu'un qui a tout les serviettes dans
un seul bac on va dire un garçon de
plage il allait lui servir des huit
personnes sauf que le garçon de plage
est nouveau et il sait pas du tout à qui
appartient qu elle serviette donc il va
des données complètement au hasard et
l'énigme al intervient tout de suite
allé déjà là ma question c'est quelle
est la probabilité plus parmi toutes ces
personnes sept d'entre elles reçoivent
leurs vrais serviette la bonne servier
je vous laisse réfléchir un petit peu à
ça vous pouvez quitter la vidéo si vous
voulez y revenir plus tard en tout cas
résister à la tentation donné la réponse
dans les commentaires je sais que ça
vous démange mais c'est résister et
n'hésitez pas à faire faux si vous avez
envie de chercher puisque je vais donner
la réponse dans trois deux un
maintenant la probabilité que cette
personne parmi les huit reçoivent la
bonne serviette et 2 0%
il n'y a aucune chance que s'arrête
alors ceux qui ont trouvé se disent bah
oui c'est évident mais ceux qui n'ont
pas trouvé doivent pas encore comprendre
et ça doit vous agacer donc je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que comme ils sont
huit
il ne peut pas y avoir cette bonne
réponse si on le prend à l'envers ça
veut simplement dire qu'il peut pas y
avoir une seule erreur si l'une des
personnes n'a pas sa bonne serviette ça
veut dire qu'il ya obligatoirement une
deuxième personne qui n'a pas la bonne
servier il peut y avoir de deux erreurs
à huit erreurs mais pas une seule erreur
c'est pour ça que la probabilité que
sept d'entre eux reçoivent l'as bien de
serviette est nu et même pas besoin de
savoir calculer c'était juste de la
logique j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de cliquer la vidéo vous
pouvez vous abonner si c'est pas encore
fait et moi comme d'habitude vous donne
rendez-vous après demain c'est à dire
dans deux jours ciao
[Musique]
non